foreign
[Music]
these aren't just any donuts they're Fox
Festival donuts with Spirit sprinkles
wanna try one no thank you but I hope
you and your mother enjoy them she's
here ah let me guess she brought her
vacuum yep
you know someone came to work with me
today and she's very excited to see you
[Music]
foreign
hey there little rabbit you're getting
so good at that
[Music]
oh but of course oh I've got something
for you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
how do I look
well I should get going see you later
little fox Mr Yoshida
pray for me
it doesn't save you anymore just last
week someone in this building was robbed
at gunpoint you should never have moved
out
I brought your groceries
mom you're overreacting I'm not
overreacting
please
tell me this is not your dinner uh
look at me I am totally protected by the
fox Spirit just like Grandma was
your grandmother is gone
and I will not lose you too
but Mom the fox Spirit can block bullets
and balance your blood sugar
she's an all-purpose kind of spirit all
purpose like flower
which makes
nuts
you know I have a sword right
I'm fine I'm so safe
you know
I stay up all night worrying about you
you've stopped training with me
kanizaka's falling apart and I I don't
know how to protect you
[Music]
faith alone isn't enough critical
mom
you may not believe in the fox spirit
or what grandma taught me
but believe in me
I'm stronger than you think
are you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
animal spirit
your song owes us a lot of money I I
already told you I don't know where he
is
you think this is a game
you think the prosperity is gonna
protect you oh yeah
yeah
I just want what's best for you kiriko
[Music]
I'm gonna kick every one of you in the
face
in the face I'm gonna call for backup
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
have prayed on this city
this neighborhood
these people
for too long
I have a message for you to take it back
to your boss
is under my protection
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
are you okay
[Music]
such a brave little fox
keep your eyes on this one
[Music]
it's growing up so quickly
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
your heart
oh
I'll be okay
[Music]
maybe I shouldn't have stopped training
with you after all
maybe
maybe I judged your Donuts a little too
harshly
maybe moving home for a little while
isn't such a bad idea
please don't cry if you cry I'm gonna
cry
[Music]
your grandma
would be so proud of you
[Music]
my baby is so superhero
oh
[Music]